hey man poing police you doing all
right
hello hey
bud top to
all right he's not responding right now
but he is
snoring hey
bud hey buddy Police
Department 104 looks like they're going
97 hey so I don't know if he was on this
ebike and 97 and pH he's snoring I mean
I see a little scrapes on his right
leg so I don't know if he was riding it
and
fell
no okay my back lights on
make there
there kind of tapped him with my foot
and noon he wasn yeah he was SN
yeah he's breathing I his belly moving y
what's
up he's got some scream a
couple
leave that right there leave that right
[Applause]
there speak Spanish
no I can get
somebody all my Spanish guys are
off this way dude you snoring when I
showed up oh sorry that was oh that's
okay I meant to hit you not much up
about you all right put some on and uh
you're fine yeah you look fine
dude you're
fine a fucking hot shower
[Music]
dude okay I see right here sit
down sit down no fine sit down no I'm
sorry I'm
fine dude sit down sit down sit
down get over here man all right at this
point back put
back what put your hand get on the
ground what anything T dude I anything I
did nothing I stop resisting I nothing I
nothing I
nothing SK it are
deployed on your
stomach I
nothing nothing man hands behind your
[Applause]
back I want
C dude why you have to make this so
difficult huh who doing you
you get anything in your
pockets
yeah
yeah police thank you
[Applause]
we got a wall back
here got to run it off thank
you hey can you call the captain hey can
you call the sergeant for me the
sergeant yeah he's right here I
appreciate it he's already here oh you
already got him yeah he's already that's
how long you do thank you you're welcome
yes
sir 274 27
hey uh I'm you trying to go back home oh
that's not going to happen
anymore oh why is that she placed under
arrest for obstructive th for the offic
I told you that you contined to resist
then you resisted arrest so you're
you're charged with both of them okay
well it doesn't matter what you say
that's what your charges are you're
going to Kingman no okay sorry sir
doesn't matter what you say those are
your charges matter what I say I'm Amic
I know and know Char okay can you guys
pull you want us to pull I can pull can
you pull right sir I disagree with
you're saying man okay that's fine you
can disagree and you can come to the
judge in the morning hey I'm going to
pull these things out of your chest hey
he you said leave them no I don't want
to leave these things here hey man this
what they want no I don't want to what
they want you just toss right
here'll I'll grab one just toss it with
that wire right there I'll grab that
hurts yeah it probably does but if you
would have listen you would had that
problem that really hurts a lot sit up
ready one oh
two put some bands on them yeah stand
up what
hurt what
hurt oh your
dignity there's not too much we can do
about your dignity sorry about
that I can't do too much about that
either it's his wrist okay they're going
to get some bandaids for him let's get
them over
tool actually we can bring him back over
there and have him sit on the the thing
[Applause]
I think it'll be okay made it this far I
think we all know what they look
like
on me like oh he's fucking showing his
penis to the public you feel me you
didn't have to go this you didn't want
to listen
to oh yeah you did dude you were
resistant no they're all standing right
here i' file I would say everybody's cam
right
here okay we got cameras going too par
you're okay I don't care man I already
won so won cool well you won your pants
on like hanging out your butt there
bro and you r in the middle of the
street that's okay we
won hold in right
now yeah I know I'll get some more drive
off
[Applause]
oh well we're trying to clean you up all
right going to stay I got
it see some bandaid would work a little
small
ones yeah you don't need good your box
shorts man you're good take take your
foot up take your foot up your foot up
sorry right foot up man I'm sorry take
your foot up real liter bro yeah I'm not
AIG
nig
got we record everything they're
recording got it hey keep T my wrist
relax it makes me feel good do let these
D treat you and then you're going
sorry I right
whatever yeah whatever I don't know what
they call it you're in the middle of the
street bro keep
going it going we got a knife and a
cigarette
lighter I go
through I was try to get by the car to
search and search no I know you but you
didn't want to
listen where you from where you
from we have an ID on him uh yeah it's
uh ran
[Music]
already you got do you need one I have
one yeah in the back of
mine pull a bottom drawer it's on the
right hand
side the I feel like I should have did
more than just try to by his arm but
that's okay walk over your left hey you
Noe get all your stuff he was walking
away
him so you think he got knocked out or
just passed out there F passed out down
ebike okay I then you just freaking
swerving it maybe even took a step off
and freaking just like all right cool no
head injuries or anything like that was
was your RP still here when you got here
yeah but he left yeah he's like I
thought he thought it was another car
and he pretty much when I pulled we'll
check on him he
that was the guy that had the brights on
there coming at me probably dick fck
would shut him off for us he didn't shut
him off for me either
yeah thank you did you find
it was he oding or what no he was like
passed out he must have been driving
that and fell off it that little E Bike
behind you and then uh didn't want to
listen he was stuck in the therough fair
and didn't want to listen and that's T
I'm
coming make sure we gathered this in a
separate bag
yeah grab a bag bag yeah I'll trade you
here I'll put this in here and then I'll
go thanks for
help guys all good in
there
I put your
R you could have told that if you would
[Applause]
listen to take the and leave
no you're fucking way underr he tries to
grab him he's all playing the fucking
game we're not going to be sitting here
just good we're good thanks I go to the
house yeah his house no my house yeah oh
oh cuz you ripped your pants right in
the GU or what right in the back
[Laughter]
look
yeah
it it should fold don't they fold down H
I don't know about the
E1 that should been in the back seat
though yeah I was going to pop him right
away and Tony's playing fucking I know I
got in your way in a minute like I was
going to just hit it and
then Tony was playing ring around to
Rosie and I was like I'm not going to
stand for this yeah I was like either I
line backer him out or he just stay this
is probably the best way to do I'm just
driving on the highway thinking down
change so I'm going to go
to for the fool
who rip his
pants